so about three years ago i moved to
ireland
um i did this because of what was
happening in my life
so as brady said i have spent pretty
much a lifetime now working on open
source
and some very important projects this is
where my office is now
it's as you can see a resort town not a
normal place for a tech office
and i went to work for this company at
least in part because
it was here and the ceo wanted to stay
where he was born
but through no fault of our own we ended
up writing the most popular covid
tracing app contact tracing app in the
world
and so this presentation is about how
you can't
ultimately change what happens to you
life just happens and
you have to go with what you know i've
had wanderlust my whole life this is
morocco i lived in morocco for two years
while i was in the peace corps right out
of college
i lived a lot of places and a lot of
really pretty places that weren't
america
and at some point i realized that you
could
travel full-time if you just got
interested in open source
and uh there are a few of us uh some of
us in the audience now that spent about
10 years
traveling full-time to make open source
real by
evangelizing it around the world and it
was really fun but the truth is my
houseplants looked like this the whole
time
i was so often gone and not home it was
kind of silly even to have a home
and i decided and maybe this was wrong
that i could change my life
by moving elsewhere um and maybe
finding a little more peace realizing
that
you know software isn't always as
important as we think it is it's not
world peace
it's certainly not super important to
humanity most of the time
um so as i said before i moved to
beautiful ireland
and it was peaceful and i loved it so
much for
two and a half years it was exactly what
i was looking for
although i was still traveling too much
and then of course we had
um you know the pandemic
and um boy it stopped everything in fact
ireland just today
decided they're stopping again because
they need to flatten their curve again
they don't have enough hospital
resources
so they have to stay on top of that
flattening
so you know we wanted to work on the
contact tracing app because we wanted to
help people get back to something like a
normal life
and not have to stay far away from each
other with fear and
you know i i'm not opposed to masks i
think they're great um but
we need ways for people to feel safe and
moreover when we wrote our app we wrote
it privacy first like
like i have never done before it's a
very small data set it doesn't know who
you are or where you are
but it's still able to help you protect
yourself and your family which is
amazing to me
we added a lot of features that the
european union didn't want us to add
like symptom trackers they wanted that
to be a separate app but we thought
if we don't put it all in one app how
are we going to get people to use all
these different bits
and this turned out to be a really
useful feature this one was even more
useful
it's information about where more cases
are so that you can make choices about
where to spend your summer
and a lot of people use this i mean we
have the best penetration of any
any contact tracer in the world almost
40 of our population
part of why that happened was because we
used open source
we open sourced the code base so that
privacy advocates could
look at it before we tried to get people
to use it and they became our biggest
advocates and that's why we have such a
big install base
then after we released it and got such a
great response we started worrying about
our neighbor to the north
northern ireland of course those six
counties are behind a border
that almost 30 000 people um cross over
every day and the uk was taking a
different tack
so we asked them if they would use our
app and they said yes
and in fact most of the uk
is using our app now just not the uk
itself or
what we think of as as britain but um
scotland gibraltar the isle of jersey
northern ireland and then we were able
to get people to use it in the us as
well so right now new york new jersey
uh pennsylvania and delaware are all
using this app that was crafted in
ireland
and that is a huge change for ireland to
have influence like that in the world
the biggest thing that happened was we
got asked to give it to the linux
foundation public health initiative
and we did do that it's called covet
green and the reason that that's
important is people who are not going to
pay
our company to create a bespoke version
we'll still be able to use this simple
technology
to combat something that's frankly
changing all of our worlds and not in a
good way
and what i'm most focused on is africa
and needing to get them the tools the
reason that they don't show any covet is
not because they don't have it it's
because they're not tracking it
so my takeaway for you today is if you
have the opportunity to download a
coveted tracing app to use in your
locale
and california is about to have that
opportunity use it and if you don't have
an
app go to covid green and try to get
your local public health initiative
interested in that
thank you